well in case you hadn't noticed I took a
big chunk out of my face what happened
wait are you serious did you have you
noticed it yeah no shaving I never do
that anymore I thought the dermatologist
no no but it's it's funny because here's
the thing I did this two days ago and
you know that I'm just shaving
um but are you just shaving or are you
like yeah
Sona tell them this is honest this is
true I think because because you've
witnessed what you do is just very like
I just want to get this over with right
like so I feel like you're just like
angrily that's what I shout as I'm
making love I just wanna get this oh
[Laughter]
it's been 40 seconds
this is intolerable
my wife is a saint uh no but I you know
he's into some kinky yeah almost
everyday things things that you just
have to do you're annoyed by well it's
not that I'm annoyed I just and I've
seen my father does this too like when
my father would wash his hands
he the way Superman squeezes a piece of
coal into a diamond that's how my father
would wash his hands there's something
in my genetic or cultural makeup which
is when I all those years Sona when I do
a show and I'd have makeup on afterwards
they'd give me these nice moist you know
towelettes that take the makeup off yeah
I would shred them against my face yeah
like I was trying to eliminate all of my
features the Sandpaper and and so what
happens is I have to tell myself when
I'm shaving
just chill
um really got it now
you guys are gonna get mad at me but I
have a very strong jawline it's not
we're not mad it's more just pity I
guess oh is that what it I don't know
like I have what I'm saying is okay I
have a very uh you know strong handsome
jawline it's when you say things like
that and um one of the canons of beauty
uh male Beauty for many years uh and so
when it has to take that turn sometimes
when I'm impatient uh and so I have this
uh deep chunk that I took out of the
side of my face here's the interesting
thing it's really noticeable and it's
and it's like a long scrape and Scar
it'll heal up in a couple days no one's
said a thing no one has said hey Conan
what happened
which makes me think that people think
that I like try to have a facelift and
tell you exactly what it is because it
is a gash that you would not associate
with just a razor Nick yeah it seems
like you have
um a condition or like you've got I
don't know shingles or something like
that Jesus well and you still didn't say
anything
why didn't you say anything well I don't
want to point that out if you would have
already known it I'm sure did you notice
it so Adam you noticed it
Adam's coming over I did we were talking
in the kitchen earlier yeah and I did
notice it but why not say hey what
happened I thought it was like you went
to the doctor and they took a biopsy
sort of yeah it is like it's a divot in
your chin Eduardo did you notice it I
did not know oh that's right you're not
really that into me or my welfare
watching the soccer games over there I
do think a lot of people who do know you
maybe saw it and were like cut himself
shaving angrily again I do classic Conan
just yeah angrily shaved his face and
ripped a part of it off but what is that
because you've seen it in action Sona
and I don't just again it's this God
gonna shave now energy and I I honestly
don't know but that's the approach I
take to eating like I'm gonna get this
food in me yeah and then I've just gotta
get to my coffin and die and I bet oh my
God I mean it's like where is this whole
thing about like brushing your teeth you
brush it angrily I do that too well
that's why I've seen you put hair
product in your hair and you're like get
a hair product I don't put hair
product in my hair
yes you do I've seen you Shauna I don't
okay I've never put hair product in my
hair that's not something I would ever
do okay I'm sorry what happened what
happened we're just gonna tell the party
line I don't put hair product in my hair
okay okay is your food thing and maybe I
can relate to this I don't really do
anymore because now I appreciate food
and you can tell because my belly's
growing I'm becoming a fat daddy but
listen is it that your meals are just
like oh these are in the way of the rest
of the day this is just utilitarian
stuff I gotta get through to you know
the way they came up with Soylent in
Silicon Valley this
um
sort of warm milky drink that gives you
pretty much everything you're supposed
to have and it was a big thing because
coders
and quote Geniuses they don't need to be
distracted they can just sit there and
go glue and glue and glue and get
everything they need while they're
coding I remembered coming up with that
idea when I was in fifth grade because I
was so intense
and focused and a little crazy that I
was thinking why isn't there just a cube
I can have like a blue cube that I just
eat and it gives me what I need and then
I can get back to hating myself so
um yeah you're so aware of it why don't
you just change change yourself
you know what I mean I don't know I mean
why don't you like when you're angrily
shaving just be like Conan no I but you
have to stop yes but you have to be on
it all the time and I am pretty good I'm
better than I used to be but then my my
wife is constantly saying to me no one's
taking that away from you we'll be in a
restaurant and I'm just and she's like
no one's taking that away from you and
she always says Neil isn't here my older
brother she's like Neil's not here he's
not going to take that pork chop
now I do think Neil is going to get that
pork chop he's in the he's in the vents
of the restaurant with a fishing rod and
a hook he's gonna get that this was a
moment where I forgot
and it's not just a little Nick I took a
piece of my face off yeah uh and what if
you do an artery or something well right
and then we have to say like oh he was
just angrily shaving his face what a way
to go it's actually not a bad way to go
what are you what bleeding out because
you you were shaving it feels like
falling asleep oh come on man Annie
anyway uh shaving shaving uh yeah just
don't shave yeah would you ever bring
the beard back I don't know it's funny
how people were kind of it's funny
people were split on the beard oh really
I said in their business I think women
liked the beard and and Men it seemed to
irritate them Will Ferrell had enraged
him he was like get rid of that beard
um he even shaved it he was the one that
shaved it off your face your choice you
could do whatever you want that's right
thank you yeah thank you no half face
beard half face no you don't have no
what that's weird no that's stupid this
is Trend setting uh what I might do is
grow crazy long uh sideburns like real
choppers you should those would look
good well I did I tried it once in the
late 90s and a uh TV critic who liked me
said nice things about me
um wrote a piece and said wrote nice
things about the show but then said
Conan uh who lately has morphed into a
Riverboat Gambler now that's not all
together bad Maverick
sharp
um but yeah I'll do something but I
don't know the beard and I did it it
felt like that was then this is now I
gotcha but uh I think you just need to
just slow down
what I fixed you
thank you Sona oh wow thank you wow
that's pretty good yeah did you fix me
no I do you're good listen I've always
good I've always thought one of the
reasons that you and I uh click if if
this is actually us clicking it is but
no it is is that you embody of the
things that I can't be and maybe I
embody some things you can't be and yeah
and so uh to be very honest you
um
you have an ability to take things as
they come and uh I've always been this
you know sort of grinding I mean Kevin
you and always talks about me back at
SNL like grinding my fingers together
yeah I mean there's something about all
that that's you know you know allows you
to
Finish Line just uh what well not the
Finish Line
you won your race
this is a shocking here's your watch
this is a horrible turn of events I mean
I'm glad I'm very fortunate
hello I bought an RV
all right well we gotta get to it
because my career is over I gotta wrap
this up